in south africa we're seeing some of the
worst political violence in that country
since apartheid
and the death toll is now up to at least
72.
this comes after former president jacob
zuma was sent to jail
deborah patta is in a suburb of
johannesburg which has seen some of the
most violent disturbances deborah good
morning
good morning south africa is on its
knees after days of violence
but so far security forces have been
slow to bring the unrest under control
hordes of looters stormed hundreds of
retail stores in south africa
grabbing anything they could get their
hands on
outnumbered and overwhelmed police
struggled to contain the violence
that hasn't been attacked and completely
ransacked
dozens are dead this man was injured in
the mayhem
nobody stopped to help him and in one
heart-stopping moment
this toddler was rescued from a building
set ablaze by rioters
the violence was triggered by the
jailing of former president jacob zuma
for refusing to appear before a
commission investigating corruption
during his nine-year
tenure his supporters took to the
streets
but it has now boiled over into a narcic
rage
fueled by persistent poverty that's been
exacerbated by a deadly third wave of
the covert pandemic
but for the shop owners victims of that
rage
it was all too we much
over a thousand arrests have been made
and now the south african military has
been deployed to hot spots
but thrown into this mix are armed
militias taking the law into their own
hands
if they start shooting there will be war
and that's the thing that we don't want
here in south africa
south africa is a peaceful country but
for five straight days that peace has
been shattered in the deadliest violence
this country has seen
in the more than 27 years since
apartheid ended
of immediate concern now some food
supply chains have been disrupted
an oil refinery has been closed and the
transport of oxygen to fight this
pandemic
has been hampered boy that was deborah
patter reporting from south africa i
have friends in south africa who said
that you can't believe what you're
seeing
it's been bubbling there for the last
five days and it's just now reaching
uh american media but they said it's
it's shocking what is happening and you
obviously saw deborah was right in the
middle of it
exactly it was very very frightening